nouveau bilan aux états unis plus de
soixante treize mille morts dus
coronavirus washington qui cherche
toujours un responsable à la pandémie
le secrétaire d'état américain a une
nouvelle fois accusé la chine cette nuit
mike pompéo qui appelle à inviter taiwan
rival de pékin à l'assemblée mondiale de
l'eau ms les 18 et 19 mai et là mais jen
les états unis n'en démordent pas
washington
il ne fait aucun doute que le coc vie 19
provient d'un laboratoire chinois
le laboratoire p4 de one plus exactement
le secrétaire d'état américain affirme m
détenir des preuves significatives mais
sans certitude sur la fuite du virus
depuis cet institut de virologie de la
province du hubei dans la foulée mike
pompéo a rappelé que la chine détenait
toujours des informations décisives
concernant le patient zéro et des
informations cruciales pour l'avancé dit
il des recherches sur le virus
les chinois disent vouloir coopérer
génial coopérer c'est agir c'est
s'ouvrir c'est partager ses informations
les détails de l'endroit où le patient
zéro a été identifiées sont des choses
qui ne sont connus que par le parti
communiste chinois
c'est lui qui peut aider à débloquer la
situation en demandant de l'aide
nous serions heureux de leur fournir
cette aide nous avons besoin le monde a
besoin de réponses à ces questions pas
seulement dans la situation actuelle
mais aussi pour éviter qu'une telle
situation se reproduise avec des
milliers et des milliers de vies perdues
et un désastre économique dans le monde
entier
mike pompey ont rejoint le président
américain qui allie et la semaine
dernière le cours aux navires us un
laboratoire chinois
le secrétaire d'état s'est toutefois
gardé de détailler les preuves en leur
possession
à l'image de donald trump mike pompéo
qui n'a pas non plus contesté la
conclusion des services de renseignement
américains selon laquelle le kovy 19
n'était pas d'origine humaine
de son côté pékin demande une nouvelle
fois aux états unis de prouver ce qu'il
avance de place de normes de sécurité
si le président américain ou le
secrétaire d'état michael p e ont des
preuves qu'il n'hésite pas à les montrer
au monde entier
si vous avez des preuves tangibles
que cela vient d'un laboratoire de wuhan
vous devez montrer ses preuves au monde
entier plutôt que de pointer du doigt
avec des accusations sans fondement une
guerre des mots initiée au mois de mars
par pékin quand le porte parole chinois
du ministère des affaires étrangères
avait laissé entendre que l'armée
américaine avait introduit le virus à
orane pendant les jeux olympiques
militaire preuves ou pas le torchon
risque encore de brûler dans les
prochains mois au coeur de cette
controverse entre les états unis et la
chine
cette question qui doit endosser la
responsabilité financière de
l'apparition du coc u19 une crise
sanitaire qui a contraint la planète
terre à prendre des mesures de
restriction au point de menacer à terme
l'équilibré de l'économie mondiale